tf1 20 heures présenté par dominique
baudis
la grève à la sncf mouvement largement
suivi 20 à 25% du trafic assuré edmond
maire à tf1 deux priorités pour la
rentrée la réduction de la durée du
travail pas de salaire supérieur à 6
fois le smic environ 12 mille francs le
norway ex france est arrivé cet après
midi aux chantiers allemands de brême
bonsoir dès le début de ce mois d'août
nous avions prévu une rentrée sociale
précoce
en effet le premier conflit s'est déjà
manifestée il affecte le trafic de la
sncf c'est d'ailleurs la première fois
depuis 26 ans que les cheminots
déclenché un mouvement de grève au mois
d'août et de l'aveu même de la direction
de la sncf
les consignes syndicales ont été
largement suivi et demain la situation
sera probablement inchangé je vous
rappelle que cette grève est organisée
par la cgt la cfdt et les autonome
elle durera jusqu'à vendredi matin 8
heures tout de suite avec françois baud
la situation sur le réseau ferroviaire
60 points seulement sur les 270
circulent habituellement chaque jour au
départ de paris sur les différents
réseaux de la sncf voit l'un des aspects
des visages de cette première journée de
grève une grève qui selon les syndicats
est suivi par 90 % des trente mille
agents de conduite
conséquences de la grève sur les grandes
lignes trains circulent sur quatre ou
cinq selon les réseaux sur les lignes de
la banlieue parisienne les perturbations
sont également importantes le trafic
n'est qu'en assurer qu'entre 25 et 40%
voilà d'ailleurs le détail garba regard
gare de l'est gare du nord gare saint
lazare
c'est pourcentage de représentent les
trafics assuré gare montparnasse gare de
lyon et gare d'austerlitz ensuite enfin
sur la ligne versailles rive gauche
aucun train est en circulation image de
la grève de bordeaux à lyon de marseille
à lille ce sont des trains à l'arrêt
dans les gares des panneaux indicateurs
d'horaires presque vide et beaucoup de
voyageurs sur les quais selon les heures
et selon les quelques trains en partance
motifs de la grève on les connaît les
syndicats veulent ainsi protester contre
la nouvelle réglementation du travail à
la sncf et s'opposer particulièrement la
mesure qui prévoit la présence d'un seul
agent lieu de deux sur certains trains
de marchandises mais en toile de fond
c'est aussi une grève pour la réduction
de la durée du travail avec diminution
progressive vers les 35 heures par
semaine selon le ministère des
transports cette grève va coûter 100
millions de francs à la sncf
enfin c'est vendredi matin à 8 heures
que le trafic doit redevenir normale sur
l'ensemble du réseau sncf
d'autre part nous apprenons que les
contrôleurs aériens de la région du sud
ouest viennent de déclencher un
mouvement de grève illimité une grève de
solidarité à l'encontre une grève de
solidarité avec ses contrôleurs aériens
qui vient d'être frappé récemment d'une
mesure de suspension se mouvant grève a
affecté tous les décollages de ligne
civil qui seront interrompus sur les
aéroports de la région concernée de la
rochelle à carcassonne et de limoges à
biarritz frappant notamment les
aéroports de bordeaux et de toulouse
monsieur non mr le secrétaire général de
la cfdt laisse entendre qu'il y aura
d'ailleurs d'autres mouvements puisqu'il
appelle à une action massive unitaire et
efficace monsieur mère faisait cette
déclaration au micro de françois go dans
une interview exclusive pour tf1 le
leader de la cfdt a porté un jugement
sévère sur la politique des trois années
du gouvernement de monsieur raymond
barre il voit la france plus affaiblie
dans son tissu économique
et plus déchiré dans son tissu social il
ajoute que s'il n'y a pas eu de
remplacement par une autre politique
ce n'est pas en raison des vertus de la
politique du gouvernement
mais à cause des insuffisances de la
gauche françois baud a demandé à edmond
maire quelles étaient les priorités pour
la cfdt il faut à la rentrée agir sur
les deux grandes priorités de l'heure et
qu'elle abat d'abord créer des emplois
en réduisant la durée du travail et en
même temps sur le deuxième point
défendre le pouvoir d'achat mais pas en
disant qu'on a augmenté tout le monde de
la même somme ou du même pourcentage du
barreau de l'échelle
non en augmentant fortement les bas
salaires en garantissant le pouvoir
d'achat des catégories moyennes et en
s'attaquant aux revenus les plus élevés
ou au salaire qui dépasse de très loin 6
fois le smic de façon à ce que l'on
réduise les inégalités dans ce pays et
qu'à travers la crise on soit capable de
sortir avec une meilleure situation des
plus pauvres est quand même plus de
justice qui vise les plus riches de ce
pays vous parlez souvent de second
souffle pour le syndicalisme qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire bien il faut sortir
de l'attitude qui consiste à nier les
problèmes difficiles
allier la crise à la limite il faut
s'appuyer même sur les difficultés ou
sur la crise pour mieux changer
par exemple il y as crise du pétrole il
y as crise de l'énergie
eh bien il faut que nous syndicats nous
ayons une proposition d'autres énergique
l'énergie nucléaire par exemple pour
répondre aux besoins du pays
il y as crise de la sidérurgie auront
lieu les deniers la crise la chirurgie
lui faut que nous ayons d'autres
propositions pour cette industrie comme
d'autres propositions industrielles
comme d'autres propositions pour
l'aménagement de chaque région et
développement de l'emploi dans chaque
région
lorsqu'on souffre du syndicaliste c'est
de retrouver cette capacité de
proposition d'innovation et de
changement dans l'unité et dans
l'efficacité et d'autre part dans cette
interview
edmond maire a révélé que la cfdt venait
d'écrire à la cgt pour lui proposer une
rencontre une rencontre après la semaine
d'action que la cgt organisera un début
septembre
et monsieur georges séguy lui a répondu
cet après midi au micro déjà plus noir
pourquoi attendre la fin de notre
semaine d'actions nous aurions souhaité
nous que les dirigeants de chaque
organisation syndicale représentative
c'est à dire la cgt la cfdt de la fen et
pourquoi pas de force ouvrière et de la
cgc se réunissent avant la fin du mois
d'août pour envisager les conditions
d'une riposte commune à l'agression du
gouvernement et du patronat contre le
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs et la
position de vie en général
nous ne voyons pas pourquoi il faudrait
attendre la mi septembre pour disputer
ensemble des conditions aussi les autres
organisations et c'est un élément
nouveau
s'ils se confirment et qui sont prêts
les dirigeants de ces organisations à
conjuguer leurs efforts aux nôtres pour
agir nous pouvons nous rencontrer
immédiatement notre semaine d'action est
décidée elle est en contrat paration
elle se prépare dans les conditions très
active avec l'a7 à la satisfaction
générale des militants et les travailler
sur nos informations mais si les autres
organisations sont décidés à agir dans
cette période là nous pouvons très bien
trouver une solution qui corresponde à
la volonté de tous et à l'unité d'action
que souhaite vraiment les travailleurs
et que nous voulons nous réaliser
concrètement êtes-vous donc optimiste et
qu'allez-vous faire donc après cette
proposition d'edmond maire pour faire en
sorte qu'une semaine d'action unitaire
puisse avoir lieu le plus vite possible
avait prendre tout contact
en conséquence je suis optimiste au
cours du mois de juillet dernier 1000
contrôles ont été effectués dans les
commerces de fruits et de légumes et ils
ont donné lieu à 93 procès verbaux pour
dépassement de la marge bénéficiaire
réglementaire c'est monsieur rené monory
qui fournissait aujourd'hui cette
indication
le ministre de l'économie a d'autre part
comparé cette polémique sur les prix des
fruits et légumes à une tempête dans un
verre d'eau
nous poursuivons ce soir sur tf1 avec
jean françois robin et notre enquête
quotidienne commencé hier
aujourd'hui la tendance est à la baisse
sur les prix à la production et sur les
marchés de gros les répercussions sur
les prix de détail sont plus lentes mais
elle commence tout de même à se faire
sentir
on enregistre effectivement une grande
stabilité et même un certain nombre de
baisses pas sur la salade dans la région
parisienne où les dégâts sont importants
provoquée par un virus et le temps
humide la laitue comme la batavia coûte
donc toujours deux francs 30 pièces en
moyenne mais vous le voyez sur ce
tableau les tomates sont en baisse de
calibre moyen mais de bonne qualité
elles devraient vous coûter demain de
francs 30 le kilo les plus belles ne
devant pas dépasser les 4 francs sur les
melons il doit aussi y avoir baisse un
détaillant nous montrait ce matin de
très beaux cavaillon à 5 francs 50 le
kilo
je vous rappelle que les prix détails
sont ceux qui doivent découler des prix
de gros
compte tenu des marges imposées pour les
produits concernés
on note sur ce marché que les prix sont
plus proches de notre prévision
aujourd'hui qu'il ne l'était hier
mis à part ces pêches jaunes un peu cher
en effet les pêches ont diminué de 50
centimes en moyenne à la production est
de 20 à 40 centimes au stade de gros un
exemple de très bonnes pêches blanches
de calibre moyen 7 francs 50 le kilo
pour le raisin chasselas et pour la
poire guyot une baisse de l'ordre de 10
centimes bien sûr nous sommes en milieu
de semaine et il est probable que l'on
enregistre une certaine remontée dès
demain à noter deux constatations
intéressante pour compenser les pertes
de salades des importations sont
effectués de belgique et ce qui est plus
rare d'angleterre et puis sur le marché
d'intérêt national de nice le rungis de
la côte d'azur
tous les chiffres prouvent une baisse
des prix de 15% en moyenne par rapport à
l'année dernière au stade de gros un
exemple ce matin les belles pêches
blanches vendu 4 francs donc
théoriquement 6 francs au détail et les
pêches jaunes de francs 80 soit 4 francs
20 au détail une information qui
surprendra peut-être parmi les hausses
récentes on enregistre une augmentation
sensible des charges locatives c'est un
phénomène qui concerne quelque 6
millions de locataires et l'on observe
d'autre part qu'au cours des cinq
dernières années les charges ont
augmenté plus vite que les loyers
une enquête de catherine mamés
les charges locatives pourrait augmenter
de 30 à 50% au cours de l'hiver prochain
monsieur baratte président des
administrateurs de biens l'a déclaré au
journal 50 millions de consommateurs
sombres prédictions quant on sait que
les hausses concernant ces charges ont
déjà atteint 46 % en cinq ans dans
certains cas chose incroyable
le montant des charges dépasse celui des
loyers principal accusé le prix du fioul
qui a augmenté de 22 et demi pour cent
en un an
une augmentation qui a des répercussions
sur le prix du chauffage bien sûr mais
également sur les factures d'électricité
en accusation également le salaire du
personnel d'entretien qui a plus que
doublé depuis 1973
cependant il serait trop simple
d'expliquer cette redoutable croissance
des charges locatives par la seule
augmentation du prix du pétrole ou des
salaires certaines eaux sont dus à une
mauvaise gestion à un gaspillage au
niveau de l'éclairage ou à des défauts
de construction qui entraîne des
dépenses non justifiées mauvaise
isolation thermique chauffage non
réglable ascenseur en surnom il faut
savoir que les charges n'évolue pas de
la même façon dans tous les immeubles
une commission d'étude créé par le
secrétariat d'état au logement a relevé
des anomalies déconcertante
ici le mètre cube d'eau coûte 40
centimes l'a330 par exemple associations
et syndicats revendiquent une meilleure
harmonisation des charges et surtout
leur contrôle par les locataires
il existe en effet de nombreux abus et
trop de beaux attributs encore ou
locataires des charges qui ne lui
incombe pas dès 1973 la commission
delmon tenté sous forme de
recommandations de réglementer
l'attribution des charges locatives
mais ces recommandations restent vaines
dans la mesure où elles ne sont pas
respectées par les propriétaires en
attendant une loi qui rendrait
obligatoire leur application les
associations de défense des locataires
conseils à ces derniers de vérifier
scrupuleusement le détail de leurs
quittances un hommage solennel a été
rendu aujourd'hui à marseille aux deux
marins pompiers qui ont trouvé la mort
en luttant contre les incendies de
forêts
milliers de personnes s'étaient
rassemblées pour assister aux obsèques
de michel albarel et jean pierre mas
l'avait dit le ministre l'intérieur
monsieur christian bonnet et le député
maire de marseille monsieur gaston
defferre on tue à l'occasion de cette
cérémonie un vif échange de propos
les marins-pompiers sont donc russe pour
la plupart des combattants volontaires
ce qui est particulièrement méritoire
malgré cela il faut que l'on sache que
le gouvernement ne respecte pas les
engagements qu'il a pris
eh les gars dans la ville de marseille
pour assurer les dépenses de personnel
de matériel de fonctionnement du
bataillon de marins pompiers
monsieur le maire ce n'est pas ici que
vous sera apporté la réponse que vous
souhaitez car j'entends respecter le
caractère de cette cérémonie
à l'issue de la cérémonie funèbre le
ministre de l'intérieur a survolé en
hélicoptère les calanques de sormiou et
de morgiou où les deux marins pompiers
ont péri samedi dernier deux mille
hectares de forêt de pinède et de maquis
qui ont été ravagés par le feu dans ce
massif des calanques entre marseille et
cassis en fin de matinée monsieur
christian bonnet a inspecté le pc de la
sécurité civile à valabre dans les
bouches du rhône
le ministre a rendu hommage aux 25 mille
hommes sapeurs pompiers militaires qui
depuis le mois de juillet en lutte et à
la limite de leurs forces contre 2080
incendie les pilotes des canadairs ont
effectué 3000 heures de vol
ils ont épuisé tout leur potentiel de
l'année depuis le début de l'été 49 1700
hectares de la forêt méditerranéenne ont
brûlé les autres années les incendie
détruisait en moyenne 20 mille hectares
nous en sommes déjà à plus du double la
sécurité civile a calculé que depuis
trente ans plus de 1 million d'hectares
ont brûlé en france alors que la
superficie totale de la forêt française
est de 15 millions d'hectares
année après année le feu frappe
constamment les mêmes massif ceux de
provence de corps du languedoc empêchant
ainsi tout reboisement dans ces régions
la france vient d'extrader l'ancien
ministre sud africain de l'information
monsieur échelle rudi il vient d'être
remis ce soir aux autorités de son père
y est celle rudi est considéré comme
l'homme fait d'un grand scandale
politique et financier qui a éclaté en
afrique du sud
il avait été arrêté en france il ya
quelques semaines est incarcéré à la
prison des baumettes à marseille
l'afrique du sud avait des pans déposé
une demande d'extradition et la justice
française vient d'y accéder dans notre
studio
monsieur alain peyrefitte le garde des
sceaux monsieur le ministre cette
affaire évoque irrésistiblement la
sphère klaus croissant qui avait
provoqué une certaine émotion en france
la décision la justice française avait
été controversé alors finalement quelle
est la doctrine du gouvernement en la
matière tantôt certains l'actualité nous
en fournit l'exemple trouve un asile en
france tantôt d'autres sont extradés la
doctrine est très simple nous appliquons
la loi la loi française sur
l'extradition de 1927 autorise
l'extradition d'un ressortissant
étranger poursuivi par la justice de son
pays à condition qu'il ne s'agisse pas
d'une infraction politique
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien la
fraction et politique et nous refusons
l'extradition ou bien l'infraction et de
droit commun et nous autorisons dans la
mesure où la cour d'appel qui a été
saisie l'autorisent nous autorisons
l'extradition
alors c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé dans le cas de monsieur roux 10
secrétaires d'état sud africain
d'information comme dans le cas de
claude poissant que vous rappelez
c'est une affaire de droit commun
la cour d'appel d'aix-en-provence à
examiner à fond le dossier qui était
présenté par le gouvernement sud
africain
elle a écouté également les arguments
opposés qui était présentée par monsieur
rudi et par ses avocats
et elle a conclu en rendant un arrêt qui
est pleinement favorable à l'extradition
j'ai moi même étudié à mon tour le
dossier minutieusement et j'ai conclu
dans le même sens alors nous l'avons
extradé tout à l'air à orly parce que ce
n'est pas une affaire politique ou plus
exactement 7
comme pour la faire klaus croissant une
affaire où il ya une apparence politique
trompeuse mais où la réalité de points
communs et une apparence politique
trompeuse parce que il s'agit d'un homme
d'envergure politique qui tient un
discours politique fait de la propagande
politique prend des positions politiques
mais il n'est pas poursuivi à cause de
ses opinions politiques à cause de la
politique qu'il fait il est poursuivi
pour une infraction de droit commun
dans le cas de monsieur vous dit parce
que il est poursuivi pour avoir
soustrait des deniers publics comme on
dit familièrement parce qu'il a pris de
l'argent du tour l'anglais l'état de
détournement de fonds détournement de
deniers publics ce qui est un crime de
deniers publics soustraction de des
publics est au contraire ce n'est pas du
tout une action politique c'est une set
une infraction de droit commun alors ce
n'est pas parce qu'on fait de la
politique que on a en bénéficient d'une
immunité pour les infractions de droit
commun que l'on peut commettre
à l'occasion de cette action politique
pour la chose est très simple et la
france reste un pays d'asile d'asile
politique
c'est sa grande tradition nous pouvons
nous flatter d'être à l'heure actuelle
le pays au monde qui a le plus grand
nombre de réfugiés politiques nous
n'avons plus de 150000 c'est à dire que
proportionnellement à notre population
nous en avons plus qu'aucun autre pays
au monde
la france reste une terre d'asile et le
restant ce mini je vous remercie le
norway l'ancien paquebot france est
arrivée aujourd'hui devant le port de
brême le paquebot doit y recevoir vous
le savez les transformations décidé par
son armateur norvégien et au même moment
une délégation de la cgt est arrivé dans
le port ouest allemands pour y
rencontrer les syndicalistes de ce pays
et leur exposer la position de la
centrale française une correspondance de
notre envoyé spécial à brême claude
bertrand personnes visiblement enchanté
vraiment paralysée par les
embouteillages de voitures pendant toute
la durée de la meneuse sur les quais
pratiquement toujours la même réflexion
dommage pour les français 17 ans mais
que voulez-vous rénové depuis moins de
travail pour tirer par la belle preuve
en est sa cote remonte heures n'aura mis
que trois heures pour arriver à quai à
proximité lequel je vous seront
effectués bientôt les premières
réparations sur membres de la famille
clos faire les nouveaux propriétaires du
navire était monté à bord à l'entrée du
port quelques heures auparavant aisé de
la nouvelle qu'ils ont existé à la
manoeuvre
c'était arrivé du norway a été marquée
également par une nouvelle manifestation
des travailleurs cégétiste de français
au compte d'une conférence de presse ont
expliqué aux journalistes allemands du
sens de leur action en déplorant
notamment que les syndicats et ap
n'est pas été concernée pendant la
discussion du contrat bertrand oui
justement à ce sujet la fédération ig
metall de la métallurgie ouest allemande
vient de rejeter toute prise de contact
avec la cgt à propos de cette affaire du
bateau à l'étranger toujours madame
indira gandhi après une dure traversée
du désert pourrait retrouver le pouvoir
d'ici quelques mois le gouvernement de
monsieur sharon singh a été renversé le
parlement indien était dissous et dans
la confusion politique qui règne dans
tout le pays madame gandhi pourrait
apparaître aux yeux de l'opinion
publique comme le seul recours un
sondage lui donne d'ailleurs 48%
d'opinions favorables dans les grandes
villes du pays
régis faucon certains voient déjà une
dire à gandhi à nouveau premier ministre
avant la fin de l'année en fait il est
probablement prématuré de parler du
retour de la fille de nez rouge sur le
devant de la scène politique mais il est
certain qu'en coulisses elle n'a jamais
cessé d'influencer la politique indienne
c'est en mars 1977 que son parti perd
les élections et qu'elle quitte donc le
poste de premier ministre
depuis cette date elle connaît une série
de victoires 2 revers et même
d'humiliation puisque elle goûte à la
prison il est vrai quelques jours
seulement 20 78 elle se fait élire
député dans un état du sud du pays mais
quelques jours plus tard elle est
expulsée du parlement pour abus de
privilèges et arrêté ses adversaires
comprenant que les plus embarrassantes
en prison quand liberté et les vite
relâchés mais la justice est plus son
dossier on lui reproche notamment les
abus commis pendant l'état d'urgence de
75 à 77 et les tribulations de son
playboy deux fils sans jay ne contribue
pas à redorer son blason
mais décidément la roue tourne et
aujourd'hui indira gandhi semble sur le
point d'effectuer un remarquable come
back
partisans et adversaires constate qu'on
ne peut se passer d'elle elle n'est pas
député mais son parti compte 74
parlementaire et ce sont eux qui ont
fait chuter le gouvernement de monsieur
charente singh en lui retirant leur
confiance c'est indira gandhi aussi qui
a emporté la décision de dissoudre le
parlement et de provoquer les élections
anticipées qu'elle entend bien gagner
en fait cette grande dame
la politique indienne n'a jamais eu
l'intention de renoncer et c'est bien le
sens de la réponse qu'elle faisait dé
l'année dernière à notre envoyé spécial
raymond girard c'était quelque chose qui
ait été autant que le pays n'arrive pas
un endroit où il ya beaucoup plus de
houla où la liberté certaine je pense
que la mission n'est pas fini les autres
nouvelles de ce journal en bref
maintenant avec vous bruno masure
tout d'abord les combats se poursuivent
au sud-liban de violents duels
d'artillerie oppose depuis quelques
jours les fausses palestine aux
progressistes d'un côté aux israéliens
et conservateurs phalangistes libanais
de l'autre bilan des bombardements
israéliens jusqu'à présent cinq morts
dont trois enfants en bas âge et 65
blessés dont trois soldats népalais de
la finul de la force intérimaire des
nations unies
certains duels d'artillerie se sont
poursuivies parfois à une cadence de un
obus par minute
le liban a décidé aujourd'hui de porter
plainte auprès du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu à la suite de ces bombardements
israéliens
mais le gouvernement libanais ne
demandera pas la convocation d'urgence
de ce conseil de sécurité d'autre part
le roi hussein de jordanie s'est
entretenu à huis clos pendant deux
heures environ avec yasser arafat le
chef de l'olp et entretiens qui ont été
dites ont couronné de succès les deux
hommes ont probablement discuter d'une
attitude commune adoptée au cours de la
prochaine réunion du conseil de sécurité
sur la question palestinienne le
président américain jimmy carter
poursuit sa descente du mississippi à
bord d'un ancien bateau à roue croisière
de vacances et de détente bien sûr mais
aussi une bonne occasion pour un
président en difficulté de faire
campagne jimmy carter continue
inlassablement sa croisade en faveur des
économies d'énergie et vous le voyez ici
faisant la démonstration d'une machine
destinée à convertir les épis de maïs en
gaz
il n'y a pas de petits profits dans la
chasse au gaspi
après une légère accalmie l'or a battu
une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui à paris
tous ses précédents records historiques
c'est ainsi que le lingot d'or a été
coté 44 1900 francs
une centaine de journalistes et ouvriers
du livre ont manifesté cet après midi
devant le journal l'aurore pour
protester contre la procédure de
licenciement engagée contre l'un des
journalistes représentant syndical au
comité d'entreprise la direction du
journal reproche à monsieur prunier
d'avoir communiqué au personnel une
information jugée par l d'ordre
confidentiel pour les syndicats de
journalistes il s'agissait en fait
d'empêcher un représentant syndical
d'informer ses collègues je cite sur ce
qui se trame dans les coulisses du
groupe hersant le rédacteur en chef du
monde andré fontaine pressenti par le
quai d'orsay pour le poste d'ambassadeur
de france à pékin aurait décliné cette
proposition
et cela pour des raisons personnelles le
syndicat force ouvrière a écrit
aujourd'hui au ministre du travail
robert boulin pour lui exprimer sa
totale opposition à une éventuelle
ouverture des grands magasins le
dimanche
la population de paris continue de
diminuer entre 77 et 78 la capitale a en
effet perdu 48 mille de ses habitants la
capitale compte maintenant deux millions
152 mille résidents villeurbanne dans le
rhône est la première ville de france à
faire officiellement appel à une agence
privée de gardiennage pour assurer la
sécurité de ses habitants
son maire le socialiste charles hernu a
expliqué qu'à villeurbanne la couverture
policière n'était plus suffisante à la
suite du départ de nombreux crs pour la
surveillance des routes et des peu des
plages il faut rappeler que villeurbanne
a été la ville a été victime de
plusieurs cambriolages l'année dernière
avec que cet appel au gardiennage privée
n'est valable que pour le mois d'août
seulement hier je vous parlais de
l'exploit d'une jeune nageuse américaine
qui avait rejoint bahamas à la floride
et bien je vous présente aujourd'hui un
nageur yougoslave vasco rossi qui a
réussi hier soir un autre exploit la
traversée de l'adriatique contre
l'italie et la yougoslavie
ce nageur a couvert les 75 km en un peu
plus de 19 heures
et il a perdu dans l'aventuré dix kilos
soit à peu près 1 kg toutes les 7 km
sainte
début aujourd'hui en lan du championnat
du monde cyclisme aujourd'hui c'était
les 100 km contre la montre par équipe
amateur sur route première l'équipe de
l'allemagne de l'est deuxième la pologne
devant la norvège et l'urss
l'équipe de france n'est que 17e sur 24
des résultats qui sont de mauvais augure
un an avant les jeux olympiques de
moscou
pour terminer je voudrais évoquer les
malheurs du summer de ce buzz il s'agit
en fait d'un commerçant de sarreguemines
spécialisée dans la location des jeux
automatiques qui venait de relever sa
recette chez les dépositaires
quand sa camionnette a dérapé avant de
s'immobiliser à proximité d'un ruisseau
résultats quinze mille pièces de 1 franc
déversé sur la chaussée
et notre homme a dû emprunter un
électroaimant pour récupérer son bien
l'histoire ne dit pas si beaucoup de
gens se sont précipités pour l'aider ne
serait ce que pour pouvoir jouer au loto
dont je vous rappelle les résultats
il fallait jouer pour gagner le 48 le 22
le 31 le 40,2 le cas le 30 4 portes et
le 48 numéro complémentaire le 46 les
prévisions météo avant de refermer ce
journal demain le temps sera plutôt
frais avec durant la matinée des brumes
et des brouillards sur le nord-est le
centre et le sud ouest l'après midi un
temps ensoleillé avec toutefois quelques
nuages passagers près de la manche et
dans le nord ces nuages pourront donner
quelques averses le dernier journal sera
présenté ce soir à 23h35 par florence
schaal d'ici là je vous souhaite de
passer une excellente soirée je vous
remercie de votre attention
oh